you know it's interesting if you have a
skin problem you go to a dermatologist
and they give you a diagnosis a label
and then you get some medication
probably a cortisone cream or some other
medication
and then you go home and you start
applying the cream and then you wonder
why you have to keep taking this cream
over and over and over
for weeks well
it could be that you haven't really
corrected the real problem and out of
all the locations of where skin problems
originate from
the liver is at the top of the list and
so we're just going to go through
all the different skin problems that
relate or are caused
by your liver and then i'm going to give
you a good solution okay
first of all itchy skin definitely liver
why because
bile is made by the liver
and then it drains out through all these
little tubes bile ducts into the
gallbladder and then it's secreted into
the small intestine
and if there's any bit of backup into
that
plumbing so to speak it's going to back
up into the blood and out to the skin
you're going to have itchiness okay next
one is
a red nose okay
this usually occurs in diabetics you'll
see that they have a redness in their
nose but it could come from other things
that they're eating too like junk food
or unhealthy food habits
red nodules
that could be from a certain medical
condition that's related to the liver
white and yellow deposits on the eyelid
that is cholesterol
backing up
into the eyelids and it's actually you
have these little cholesterol deposits
or fatty deposits on the eyelid that's
related to the liver now of course
jaundice is where your skin and eye
whites are yellow because of this back
up through the bile ducts into the blood
and into into the skin i remember one
time my skin turned
um orange okay now that that's not
jaundice because john just has more of a
yellow tint
but it was because i was consuming
massive amounts of carrot juice okay
which i no longer do all right next one
is spider nevi which is a liver problem
and it's kind of like a looks like a
little bit of a a red dot with these
little spider webs coming out from it
that is related to too much estrogen
because the liver buffers estrogen so
that's another function of the liver
that can turn into a male function
another one is where you have this like
red purple plaquing
on your either your elbows or your arms
or your legs that comes from another
condition related to the liver
red palms is a symptom
of a liver issue there's something else
called paper money skin where if you
were to look at the maybe the abdomen
legs or arms it has like a texture or a
look of wrinkled up money now if you
have too much
iron built up in your body like this
accumulation of iron because you have
another condition where you can't get
rid of iron at all and it becomes very
toxic
your skin becomes gray or bronzed and
actually what's happening your liver is
becoming cirrhotic or you're developing
cirrhosis advanced scar tissue
i talked about a red nose you could also
have an enlarged red
bumpy bulbous nose with another liver
condition all right another condition is
the eczema
very common in liver conditions but what
do people take for this condition skin
creams cortisone cream the problem is
cortisone creams in prednisone which is
a synthetic version of cortisol destroys
the liver even more so it actually
worsens the condition
white nail beds even though it's from
your nail their skin underneath the nail
that could be an indication of liver
damage
rosacea
the redness on the cheeks
that's a liver condition it can also be
an alteration in your bowel which also
you're probably gonna at the same time
have a liver problem then you have red
papules which are these red little dots
on the skin
is related to the liver and so as you
can see there's a lot of skin problems
that are related to the liver
and one point i want to make about drugs
when people take drugs like for example
statins for example you can get blisters
on the skin
peeling on the skin
burning in the skin a red rash for
various reasons and one could be they
might deplete your nutrient levels in
your body and then create the skin
problem like a b2 or b3 deficiency will
also create all of these symptoms right
here
all right so what is the solution of
course we want to improve the liver
there's some immediate things you can do
to see a nice change and that would be
number one start taking tudka tutcom
is a synthetic
type of bile salt but it doesn't appear
to have any side effects only positive
effects
and they made it synthetic because it's
a chemical very similar to bare bile
okay bear bile they used to use that as
a natural remedy until they were killing
too many bears so they made a synthetic
version which is a good thing
it's called tutka and tatka is very
unique in that it can help increase the
flow of bile that is kind of stagnant in
the liver and the bile duct so it opens
up the flow and allows things to drain
out and since most of these skin
problems are a backup of stuff that's
coming out to the liver in this
in the blood and then the skin tuck it
is a really good remedy so you can take
that an empty stomach take two maybe in
the morning and then maybe another one
in the afternoon or just two in the
afternoon depending on how bad things
are and i think you should see some
change right away okay so that's number
one as you then correct the real cause
which is probably related to your diet
so you get on keto the healthy version
of course and start doing fasting which
will greatly improve your skin
milk thistle is a really good remedy as
well it's one of the top natural herbs
with very little side effects that
protects the liver against poisons but
it also can help regenerate liver cells
and the last thing are probiotic foods
like fermented foods really good for
your liver as well as for your large
intestine
now i think the next most important
video for you to watch would be on the
relationship between
fasting
and your skin so check that one out i
put it up right here